there's roughly between nine and ten
millionaires that we can document in
North America that's someone who what
you own minus what you owe your assets
minus your liabilities equals 1 million
dollars or greater if you're one of
those we'll take your call this hour
because we want our listeners to learn
from you what does a typical millionaire
look like and what did they do to get
there because there's a lot of
misinformation out there a lot of lies
out there and a lot of stupidity out
there regarding economics and it's just
crazy
it's just crazy you guys so the truth is
is that America is not broken and you
still can leave the cave kill something
and drag it home you can still win and
people don't become wealthy on average
by being crooks and people don't become
wealthy on average by being a
professional athlete and entertainer or
a an actor or an actress a movie star
now many of those people are
millionaires but the typical millionaire
is not that less than 1% of millionaires
fall into that category the number one
career filled in for millionaires
self-employed they own a small business
that's the number one career field last
guy we talked to his a dentist he was
you know you could put him in a
professional category but he owned his
own business - and it's over one third
of millionaires on their own small
business and that's how they got there
Paul is with us in Knoxville hey Paul
how are you hey I'm doing great day God
so what's your net worth about 1.3
million very cool what's it invested in
um it's besides the house being about
three hundred thousand I guess the rest
of it - 401ks IRAs Roth okay so mutual
funds and those are fun yeah I'll make
you fun yeah okay retirement all right
so three hundo how old are you 60 60 all
right and how much of this money there's
1.3 million did you inherit 17,000 okay
not exactly a difference-maker okay now
what what's your average income been
through
your last you know your last 3040 years
of working life well I started about
$15,000 back in 1978 so I guess the
average of 50,000 s over the linear
progression yeah and what do you make
these days about 100 about a hundred
yeah what was your highest hundred okay
all right so 15 up to a hundred all
right and capping out of 100 now what do
you do for a living huh
i Technical Sales and support al Qaeda
all right and do you have a four-year
degree uh yeah a bachelor's degree in
the physics in physics okay and what was
your what was your GPA do you remember I
think I almost got the three point oh
okay yeah me too I decided to nine seven
pissed me off yeah alright and how much
of this money that you have the one
point three million in mutual funds and
you're paid and you're paid for home I
assume three hundred thousand how much
of that is do you how much did you use
debt to cause you to build wealth uh
other than the mortgage on the house
nothing I guess
okay all right yeah and what partner has
giving played in your financial plan
throughout your working well yeah we
made a decision I first got married that
we were going to try those.i well
thought out with two or three percent
see how that field and it felt awful so
we just thought the right up to ten
percent back in the late 70s and that's
okay there ever since until we're
falling out the kids college and now we
run about 15 to 17 percent of donations
you most of that tithing and then you
know the rest of it we give their try to
gives our kids for just gifts or
vacations and stuff like that what's the
most expensive pair what's the most
expensive pair of jeans you've ever
bought well maybe twenty-five dollars
okay all right how many new cars have
you bought since you said you I mean
before you became a millionaire oh I
thought to bet my class was 1982 and it
paid off in 86 that's left car pay
member ed and then when I was 30 and
then when we turned 40 we got the house
paid off so basically we just buy used
cars now
but do we have now probably aren't worth
$15,000 together okay so people are
listening out there they're going this
guy makes 100 grand he's got a million
three how did you do that what's the
secret that caused you to be a
millionaire at age 60 starting from
nothing literally well we became
intentional by 1980 when we knew want to
do something and then was discover Larry
Baquet way back then and actually became
a counselor eventually and stuck to the
budgeting and the investing and the
staying out of debt paying up house and
that's seven years after we made the
decision to get it paid off you know
that kind of thing just stuck with a
plan and still pretty much try to live
and we would get kind of loosely going
out to eat that kind of stuff but we
still pretty frugal just try to enjoy
our time with a family and the things
that are important what's what's a plan
what's a big time blowout luxury crazy
expensive thing you did one time big
blowout yeah well I can't look like okay
okay all right that's cool that's fair
that's fair
all right I mean what about it what
about a super expensive vacation have
you ever done one of those no yes the
goal big cases a lot but you know to
$3,000 we are getting ready to spend a
few thousand on the go visit our son on
California with his family take some
family with this but you know six eight
thousand dollars is a lot of money for
us to spend on a vacation gotcha
that's about it okay very very cool okay
so do you think in today's world that a
young version of Paul that's graduating
with a physics degree with a 3.0 coming
into the marketplace could do what
you've done starting today yeah
absolutely in fact it's kind of neat to
watch our children follow the same path
and you know it's hopes I think of them
being in the same place 20 30 years down
the road so yeah absolutely because
we've we have done a special just got
potentional and stuck to the plan and we
you know we live well I mean we don't we
don't be super cheap anymore especially
very cool and it's been a fun journey
well thank you thank you for taking time
to talk to us sir you're great American
hero
another millionaire that started from
nothing inherited
I mean 17,000 bucks out of 1 million 3
so obviously that doesn't move the
needle and with 1.3 million dollar net
worth as a in technical sales there it
is I mean that this is how you do it
so all millionaires inherited their
wealth is a lie it's a lie
all of them are crooks these are just
working guys I mean that there's some of
them I mean the you know a lot of them
I've got a 4-year degree some um I've
got some graduate work on their belt but
they're not overly educated necessarily
that they just show up and do it very
steady very predictably they're not
again they didn't just sign with the
Denver Broncos or they didn't just sign
you know in the NBA or are in to sign a
you know a record deal they're smart but
very few of them are brilliant very few
more rocket scientists and you know it's
just it aggravates a crud out of me
because it steals people's belief that
it can still be done and the only way
that you'll ever have anything is if we
change our economic system because
wealth inequality has gotten so out of
whack well I mean that guy saved his
money his next-door neighbor didn't save
his money
that guy has 1 million 3 the next-door
neighbor has a mortgage now you tell me
how that's unfair it's not unfair it is
fair a farmer that doesn't plant corn is
not entitled to a crop you reap what you
sow there's a cause-effect issue of this
when you work more hours you typically
make more money that's fair so for
income to be equal because talent isn't
equal work ethic isn't equal for net
worth to be equal would be unfair
be unfair for Bill Gates to have sold as
many computers as he sold and to have my
net worth and my income that would be
unfair see we've got to break the back
of the stupidity that's floating around
out there this dadgum everybody got a
trophy thing is screwing up our culture
you guys this is the truth it's not a
political thing it's a stupid thing and
stupids out their own parade and that's
one of the reasons we started doing
these millionaire themed hours so we
think these millionaires we think
they're rock stars this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show if you didn't know I
actually have my own YouTube channel so
I had two videos twice a week on life
and money so you can click the subscribe
button to subscribe to my channel and
you want to check out our video right
now check out the video on how to make a
budget